Kenny interviewed freshmen and seniors
at his high school asking them how many
pieces of fruit they eat thee they eat
each day the results are shown in the
two plots below and so the first the
first statement that we have to complete
is the mean number of fruits is greater
for and let actually let me go to the
actual screen is greater for we have to
pick between freshmen and seniors and
then they say the mean is a good measure
for the center of distribution of and we
pick either freshmen or seniors so let
me go back to my scratch pad here and
let's think about this so let's first
think about the first part so let's
let's just calculate the mean for each
of these distributions and I encourage
you to to pause the video and try to
calculate it out on your own so let's
first think about the mean number of
food for freshmen so essentially we're
just going to take each of these data
points add them all together and then
divide by the number of data points that
we have so we have one data point at 0
so we have one data point at 0 so I'll
write 0 and then we have two data points
at one so we could say plus two times
one and then we have two data points at
- right plus two times two and then
let's see we have a bunch of data we
have four data points at three so you
could say we have four threes so let me
circle that so we have we have four
three plus four times three and then we
have we have three fours
so plus three times four and then we
have a 5 so plus five and then we have a
six I'm going to do this in a color that
you can see and then we have a 6 right
over here plus 6 and how many total
points did we have well we had one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14
Oh actually we carefully had 15 points
and I didn't put that one in there so
actually let me just so we have 15
points and I can't forget this one over
here so plus my pin is acting a little
funny right now but we'll power through
that
plus 19 plus 19 so what is this going to
be so this is just going to be zero this
is going to be two this is going to be
four this is going to be twelve my pin
is really acting up it's almost like
it's running out of digital ink or
something and this is going to be
another twelve and then we have five six
and 19 so what is this going to be 2
plus 4 is 6 plus 24 is 30 plus plus 11
is 41 plus 19 gets us to 60 60 divided
by 15 is 4 so the mean number of fruit
per day for the freshman is for pieces
of fruit per day so this right over here
that right over there is our mean four
they let me put that in a color that you
can actually see now let's do the same
calculation for the seniors so we have
one data point where they didn't need
any fruit at all each day not not too
healthy then you have one one so I'll
just write that is weak I could write
that as one times one but I'll just
write that as one then we have two twos
so plus two times two then we have one
two three four five threes five threes
so plus 5 times 3 and then we have we
have three three fours so plus 3 times 4
and then we have two 5s plus two times 5
and then we have a 6 we have a 6 plus 6
and we have a 7 so I'm going to eat 7
pieces of fruit each day a lot of fiber
plus 7 and now how many data points did
we have well we have one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 data points so we're going to
divide this by 16 so what is this going
to be this is just 0 let's see this is
just right over that's
zero this is four this is 15 this is 12
this is 10 so we have 1 plus 4 is 5 plus
15 is 20 plus 12 is 32 plus 10 is 42 42
plus 6 is 48 48 am i doing 42 plus 6 is
48 plus 7 48 plus 7 is 55 did I do that
right let me do it one more time 1 plus
4 is 5 plus 15 is 20 32 42 42 plus 13 is
55 so this is equal to this is equal to
55 over 16 which is the same thing as
let's see that's the same thing as 3 & 3
that 3 times 16 is 48 so 3 and 7/16 so
the mean for the seniors the mean for
the seniors 3 and 7/16 as right around
let's see this is 3 that's 4 so 7/16
it's a little less than a little less
than 1/2 it's right right around right
around there so the mean number of
fruits is definitely greater for the
freshmen they have 4 on their mean
number of fruit eaten per day is 4 vs. 3
and 7/16 the mean is a good measure for
the center of the distribution of so
when we think about whether it's
freshmen or seniors so the mean because
is is fairly sensitive to when you have
outliers here for example someone here
was eating 19 pieces of fruit per day
that's that's an enormous amount of
fruit they must be only eating food you
could imagine if it was even a bigger
outlet if someone's eating 20 or 30
pieces of fruit just that one data point
will skew the entire mean upwards that
wouldn't be the effect on the mode
because the mode is the middle number if
even if you change this one point all
the way out here it's not going to
change what the middle number is so the
mean is more sensitive to these to these
outliers so these really these points
that are really really high
really really low so and because because
the seniors don't seem to have any
outliers like that I would say that the
mean is a good measure for the center of
distribution for the seniors or a better
measure for the center of distribution
for the seniors so let's fill both of
those out so the mean number of fruits
is greater for the freshmen and the mean
is a good measure for the center of
distribution for for the seniors and you
actually even see it here we saw that
the mean number for freshmen was at 4
but if you if you just ignore this
person right over here just you kind of
thought about the bulk of this
distribution right over here for really
doesn't look like the center of it the
center of it looks closer to 3 here and
what happened is is this one person
eating 19 pieces of fruit per day skewed
the mean upwards while here that 3 and
7/16 really did look closer to the
actual distribution closer to the
actually I shouldn't say I mean both in
both times we actually did calculate the
mean of the actual distribution but here
since there's no outliers it does seem
the mean seemed much closer to I guess
you could say the middle of the middle
of this pile right over here let's check
our answer and we got it right